what is up boys and girls it is Jerry on
the scene on the beat on the something
or other I just got out of a flick I saw
a new movie very tired I've been working
a lot it's past couple of days so I'm
very sleepy but um I just saw a film and
I was awake through the whole thing so
let's talk about it I just got out of
the new Blumhouse motion picture
unfriended that's right the spooky
webcam movie from the folks who brought
you such other films as insidious and
sinister the paranormal activity
franchise the purge Lords of Salem
various other upcoming films and um this
is interesting in a sense now this movie
you can kind of say is sort of a
different take on or an escalation
perhaps of the found-footage craze you
know found footage is really big these
days we get a lot of those movies now
that sort of restrictive first person
POV perhaps multiple cameras but you
know using those parameters to conjure
up scares and this movie sort of takes
it one step further and plays everything
just from the point of view of a few
people's webcams that are left on as
they're all you know chatting and
whatnot this movie centers around a
group of sort of you know high school
students I think high school seniors and
it also takes place in the wake of the
suicide of one of their peers of video
which has gone viral depicting this um
in that sort of the place where the
movie
finds its its roots its its most
insidious seeds so um things start out
normal enough with these people you know
talking to each other we get a little
chitchat here and there and then a
mysterious account starts to establish
its presence in their conversation and
in their interaction and then spooky
[ __ ] starts to happen and that's really
the gist of this movie and um you know I
gotta say first impressions and whatnot
this is actually kind of a cool movie um
you know it could have gone either way
you know you're sitting there thinking
okay this movie is gonna be told through
the use of webcam only but this could be
really cool this could be kind of silly
but actually for the most part ends up
being kind of come on a lot of that is
thanks to the actors um you know the
acting in this movie there there's some
people you probably recognize I
recognized a few of these folks myself
you know young actors and actresses and
whatnot but for the most part throughout
this movie um they do a pretty good job
because a lot of these are long takes
you know there was probably some
manipulation going on with you know cuz
the glitch enos inherently of webcams
allows you to play with stuff like that
but there are some long takes and pretty
lengthy you know sort of expositions and
I think the actors for the most part do
a pretty good job there are times when
you sort of feel like perhaps they
reached like a beach in the outline of
the story where they had to get
information across and then there are
times when it feels a little bit forced
but there's a lot of stuff in here you
know especially when things start to get
intense that are pretty well acted and
and you know sort of earnestly done and
also you know the actors I think sell
this a lot and also the style does and
there's a lot you can get away with and
there's a lot of really creepy mood and
sort of ominous tone you can you set
just by using artifacting on a computer
screen and they use that to really
effect in this movie even just the sort
of glitched out universal pictures
bumper that comes across the screen does
a good job at the beginning of sort of
putting you you know uneasy um I feel
like a lot of people I spoke to
beforehand kind of rolled their eyes the
trailer was like has maybe webcam moving
you know um but you know this is one of
those little things one of those little
nuggets that has a a clever little
gimmick and and it actually manages to
make that gimmick work pretty well and I
think it uses it to pretty good effect
um you know they find reason to keep
everybody at the computer you know you
have this sort of supernatural situation
where they're not quite sure if
someone's just doing a really horrible
internet prank or if they're actually
being you know a [ __ ] with for lack of
a better term by the spirit of this girl
who committed suicide and and and a lot
of this plays on some pretty relevant
topics at least in this day and age it's
a very modern movie in a kind of
interesting way and I think the the
gimmick actually doesn't get in the way
of that it actually helps that and it
helps also that the movie doesn't
outstay its welcome it's not a super
long movie it's not really all that
overwrought once things get going they
pretty much keep going and there are a
lot of actually little nuances at least
in the way that that the movie gives you
glimpses into how people talk on
computers like it's it's very modern in
that way and a lot of the just
interactions ring true you know you
watch at least the one main character
who scream you're sort of peering into
the whole time you know you watch her
type things to various people and it's
that it's that thing we all do I think
where you sort of start typing one thing
and then you reconsider you go back you
edit it then you erase the whole thing
and type something completely different
and it's little little touches like that
that I thought were actually very clever
in and like people really the people who
made this movie really took the time to
kind of
down and you know think it out in a
realistic manner and it's not to say
that the movie always is on point
there's certain lapses in logic
especially later on in the movie where
you're like oh you know after a certain
point you wouldn't even think you could
get away with certain things but the
movie as a whole I think works pretty
well it's pretty earnest and it's got a
little bit of everything in terms of
poor I mean there are definitely some
cheap jump scares that you're going you
know get a good chuckle at I got a good
chuckle out of you roll your eyes and on
to the next one and then there are
actually certain things especially when
the movie gets down to the sort of nasty
side of high school interactions you
know bullying both in person and online
and just you know sort of how horrible
people can be to each other in this day
and age especially with anonymity and
stuff like that you know all the things
you see posted on videos and stuff like
that I think it's kind of an interesting
portrait because it is very reflective
of our time of the way we communicate
and the way that affects things like
bullying and cruelty and all that you
know it's not like a masterpiece it's
still a lean little horror movie they're
still kills to be concerned about but it
does have some interesting wallpaper and
I do appreciate that about this movie I
appreciated that stuff more than I
thought I would and it just had these
little flourishes that I wasn't
necessarily expecting that that made the
movie that much more enjoyable for me it
takes that relevant topics and it builds
a nifty a neat if you will little sort
of supernatural slasher thing around
that and I appreciate that you know
because they're throughout horror
history there are all these little
movies that are just kind of service
portraits of the time they are made in
just as much as they are about scares
and chills and kills and all that and as
for the kills and the effects and stuff
they're a little bit uneven for me in
this movie I mean there are a couple
kills that are pretty icky and gruesome
and almost borderline on
enough um which you know for the purpose
of a horror movie I guess it's a good
thing there's some that that didn't work
as well for me and I think the way the
kills are positioned in the movie just
kind of put punches in places where
maybe I guess some of the kills left me
wishing that some of the other kills
have been a little more intense or a
little more you know sherlocky and
graphic and whatnot but that's just sort
of the horror fan in me there are
certain scenes that are just you know
depicting the cruelty of the bullying
this girl endured that are ugly and you
feel uncomfortable you feel bad you know
watching them and I think that's
important and those seats are effective
because they make you feel icky and
uncomfortable um and I appreciate when a
horror movie can do that it might not
blow your mind but there are a lot more
little details and little nuances and
little you know elements that are
actually cool and worth appreciating in
it and it's clear that somebody put time
and thought into this it's a very
low-budget simple enough premise but I
think the execution is solid you know
it's a solid little horror movie with
some neat ideas and some neat approaches
they actually managed to make looking at
a computer screen for you know 80 or 90
minutes hard to look away from like it's
actually kind of thrilling and it's
actually kind of engrossing if you don't
want to leave your seat you know so yeah
if you're into this you know you got
some friends together on a Friday night
you know there are there are parts where
you'll have fun that are that are
entertaining and humorous are other
parts that are you know uncomfortable
and unsettling some things you might
jump at some things that might make you
feel a little icky but altogether I
think it's an effective movie and I
liked so yeah that's it for now what
would you like to see happen with the
sort of found footage you know guerrilla
style or naturalistic you know horror
genre stuff you know what would you like
to see happen with that next as always
like comment subscribe be nice to your
fellow comment ears you can check us out
real rejects on Facebook sand on the
Twitter the Instagram I also AM reasons
to Jerry on Twitter and Instagram
that's it for now unfriended is the film
Blumhouse universal picture I am Jerry
cheers